so welcome everyone and thanks once
again
today as erin said we're going to look
at what are some things you should be
thinking about if you're building a
machine learning powered
search application and that can mean
many things right
in many different scales in production
but the intention of this
presentation is to kind of give you the
full view of things that you should be
looking out for
all right at different scales i'm a
senior data scientist at nvidia
a lot of this work in the presentation
was done
at my prior employer lucid works my
co-presenter john look moyu um he also
implements production skills search
engines for a company
with soho square and they kind of
consult with lucid books to
you know do some pretty big search
implementation so
hopefully you find some of the things
that we've learned over that time useful
and let's dig in
perfect so we're going to cover sort of
three
high-level topics call it that way first
we're going to look at
hey what's this new landscape of search
recommendations
if you follow a lot of machine learning
literature you're going to find that
there's just tons of buzz in the nlp
space and computer vision space
next we'll dive a bit more into what
those considerations were that i was
mentioning before
and lastly which i think to me is the
most important part of this presentation
is what are you going to do with your
signal data
and signal data simply means all of the
user interactions that are happening on
your site
if you're not leveraging that today
you're leaving a lot of money on a table
or a lot of improvement
on your search perfect
so i'd like to begin with this statement
and this was from a
senior vp at google who i think he's
been there for a long time
every single link uh if you see
something on the line in this
presentation uh these slides will be
available on my linkedin and on john's
linkedin
is a link to a separate thing so
you know this presentation is meant for
you to be able to find all these
resources
that you need but he's saying hey this
search thing is not going to it's not a
solved problem and this is someone at
google saying this right and they've
been working on it for decades
and they have you know the most
computational power the most
data possible to generate really good
search
and you know they're saying hey it's not
a solved problem okay so just keep that
in mind in terms of
if you get frustrated with your own
search like it is a hard problem it's
not very easy
this this next slide i know it's a
little um
sort of ambiguous but the reason why i
put this here is if you're a product
owner search owner
or you're doing any type of thing where
you can enable
information discovery um really think
about your users
because i think as you start to try to
put these things in production
or do production level search you want
to have a firm view of what people
want within the context of your business
right so that allows you to hone in
and not waste a lot of time researching
other things
the three domains that we'll kind of
focus on today
they are e-commerce in internal company
search
and customer support and the reason why
i sort of put these up here
um i think these are three big errors of
opportunity
and the corresponding thing that follows
the arrow
is the objective you're trying to sort
of maximize or the thing you're going
after
right folks want to make a ton of money
in ecommerce for internal companies
search like
people want to find stuff so they can
get their job done and for customer
support
you know finishing cases right so for
instance
if you come onto my you know support
portal and you can find an answer
without talking to someone i've saved a
lot of time
right so you'd please keep in mind a lot
of the practical implications of all the
machine learning that you do
in search and recommendations and this
last statement
put yourself in the issues of a user
but also kind of remember that you know
some research strategies can be applied
to these different domains so
you can learn things from you know if
your internal search
you can learn things from e-commerce and
vice versa
all right let's hop hop into this new
landscape and
the statement below says machine
learning influences heavily
and i think the main bottleneck that
existed before
was there was not hardware to actually
put machine learning into production
into ranking systems and recommendation
systems but now the hardware is in such
a state
that you know you can deploy some quite
sophisticated algorithms
so just for funsies i went on archive
and i looked
up information retrieval and recommended
systems just to get a peek at how many
papers were there
and as you can see right there are
you know a couple hundred to a couple
thousand mentions of both
information retrieval and recommender
systems i'm definitely not claiming that
these
papers are all about these topics but
the fact that they sort of show up when
you search
means that a lot of active research is
happening in these areas so let's define
search very simply the focus
everything is about relevance right you
put in a query and you want some things
these things that i return to you
are technically we're going to call them
relevant and relevance has
many different definitions depending on
your domain
more relevant means more similar and
the one of the other reasons that i put
this here is as you start switching over
into a machine learning based
ranking system you know more similar
means
it translates to a closer distance right
because the thing that you're searching
for now exists as some vector in a
vector space
and then you you know you search by
distance so your closest distance means
that you're more similar
content not only text similarity is the
name of the game so i know i just read
that
straight off the slide but what i'm
really trying to communicate here is
a lot of search engines prior to the
machine learning driven ones
were lexical based search right you're
using edit distances
overlapping of words between what
someone put in versus what's in the
index
but now you're seeing a lot of different
types of content being used to match a
query to
different objects right so it could be
the image it could be
other meta text it could be signals so
it's not only the text that you
originally indexed that can be used to
give you better results
let's take a look at this amazon search
page right and we're just going to
sort of look at the structure but point
out some things that you need to
consider
when developing your sort of search
pipeline so at the top you have your
search bar
that's where all of the information
comes in that is the golden ticket that
you'll sort of see at the end of the
presentation
on the left hand side you have your
facets that are typically driven
by how your data is indexed so that's an
area of opportunity to do machine
learning as well because now
you can deploy ranking algorithms to
rank your actual facets right based on a
query
what should be the best facets and
that's like a big ask
especially in e-commerce because some
items can have
you know dozens and well yeah and
e-commerce like i said let's say if you
take into consideration electronics you
can have hundreds
of different facets right so how can you
get the best facet
to the top to engage someone into making
a butchers
now notice i i did i kind of cut off the
actual results that were shown here and
i left this sponsored section at the top
this is very important thing to consider
is no matter what machine learning that
you do at the end of the day
especially in e-commerce there is a
either merchandise or some
owner or export that should be able to
override all of the results that come
from the algorithm
so you want to make sure that whatever
model you're pulling results from
able to sort of deliver excuse me
deliver those types of
recommendations or search results
when it comes to recommendations we're
going to focus on two things items for
items
items for user items for item can be
split into many different ways right
almost every recommendation can be
viewed as that so given a particular
item
what item should i recommend and we'll
look at some next
and then items for user given your user
id
what should i be showing to you right
that's more or less personalization
in a nutshell and there you know quite a
lot of strategies
there when it comes to the types of
algorithms that you see like any
tutorial that you look on recommender
systems you'll see these two words
collaborative filtering all you want to
focus on is
i'm recording all of the interactions
that are happening with my site someone
puts in a query they click something
then they purchase it then they you know
they order it again all of those events
i put those together
typically in some matrix factorization
algorithm some of the deep learning
approaches are slightly different but
i'm trying to
find out which users are similar and
then those algorithms
automatically give you what are the best
things to recommend for you
right but keep in mind those things have
no idea
about what you know what's actually in
the content
of the things that you're recommending
whereas content based
actually excuse me starts matching on
the content
within let's say your text documents or
your product descriptions
and then you start thinking about
matching across images as well
and in the brackets the thing with a
collaborative filtering recommender
any of them most times you suffer from
the cold start problem so i get a new
item how do i
give recommendations for that there's
some creative strategies there but
that model needs to be updated every
single time to include
new things and that's where content base
is typically used to solve that problem
all right let's take a look at some of
these recommendations on
amazon and the reason that i put the
slide up here i want you to think about
these three boxes what different types
of data or algorithms or type of
algorithms
i would have to use to produce that type
of recommendation
and what's kind of cool is when you
search you search with a text query
right you put that into the search bar
and you get some results when you're
doing recommendations you actually just
search with
you know that item essentially is your
query and you're going to be given some
results
so on the bottom left in order for me to
deliver frequently bought together
recommendations
i'm going to need some purchase signals
right in terms of hey i need to go
analyze
all the things that were bought and find
out things that were co-occurring
right so sometimes you'll see that to
deliver really good recommendations
it's a fairly straightforward process
right versus
this one where it's just for you from
our brand so if you sort of split that
sentence
just for you is a little more
personalized right so i may be tracking
some of the things that you've looked at
before
but i'm also boosting all the brands
that i want to show you right i think
this top one
may be sponsored it might be on this
side and
over here i point out both collaborative
and content based and the reason why i
say that is
look at the images and this is my
hypothesis completely
but you know just explore with me
the images look very similar right so
as you sort of start looking at seo
or the future of seo i think what you're
going to start seeing um there's this
whole new
thing about recommendation marketing so
instead of you actually trying to rise
to the top of the search result for a
particular query
you are going to just try to be the next
thing that's recommended
after someone has purchased something or
clicked something right
and that is both a function of the
similarity of the content
both the text and the image but in
addition to you know the user activity
that
is is being interacted with your item
okay
a quick definition on signals as it's
saying here it's
pretty much anything that someone's
doing on your platform
right so someone puts in a query you
want to capture that you also want to
tie that to the corresponding
you know post event either click cut
purchase download
whatever type of interaction is
meaningful for your
business however one of the things that
you actually don't see in production
or i haven't seen very much is this
notion of a back signal
so someone puts in a query they click
something and they're like i don't like
this and i go back
right so if you actually have that time
sequence of
data you can remove a lot of noisy data
and actually train some pretty cool
algorithms from there and
for most really good search platforms
they're using signals if you're not
using signals then
um you just start using signals i would
say
and you you see tremendous improvements
in your search it won't be perfect right
you'll see that as we move along
in this presentation and this comment
down here about privacy
this is going to be a challenge
especially for folks in europe
where you know gdpr is is sort of
prevalent
the interesting question comes about
if i use your signals i don't know who
you are i just have some user id i know
you clicked
these 10 items and you purchased these
five items but i
don't see your name i don't see anything
that's revealing of you
but i use that in my model okay so
somewhere in my model
is some inherent notion of what you've
done i can't actually extract it from
the model
but it lives in there so the question
becomes
do you have the right to now force me to
retrain my model without your data right
so those are interesting discussions
or things that you may face in different
domains
all right so content is not enough to
dominate the market
and the reason why i put this here is
to encourage you to think about you do
need signals right it's not just about
the content that you've indexed
and you get this perfect type of search
every single day people are being
trained
by google to expect a world-class search
especially in internal environments
and you know the second statement about
people ruling the world with signals
there's a very simple reason for that
and it's
this all right if you've noticed that
google's been around for
how many how many years and their site
has never changed
there's just one thing that you can do
is give them data
right they don't allow you to browse and
explore anything else
they want you to create this association
and to me this is you know one of the
most powerful data sets
that you could ever create right this is
within your business this is within
um you know big search providers that's
why apple and microsoft are desperately
trying to get you onto their browser
so that they they can make these
associations right and once you start
piling on deep learning onto this
like some of the things that they can
come up with or understand
in your queries are quite cool okay
so just think about this everyone who's
doing search in this present you know in
in this call today
hopefully you you have access to this
type of data just go ask i don't know
where those logs are
and basically just create data sets like
these and
you get to do a lot of really cool
things
now there's a tricky part
okay if you this is a little more for
e-commerce businesses or
i would say maybe large large platforms
right that need a lot of traffic when
someone searches on google and google
redirects them to your site
what ends up most times happening is
this
right you'll just see someone come on
your site oh they're clicking things
they're buying things cool
but you don't have the original query
that they came in with so that means
that
you actually don't have the real power
in the data to produce
you know sort of world-class ranking so
as much as you can
to try to grab that data it'll be to
your benefit
right so for instance someone goes on
google they enter your site and then
they really start searching on your site
you start to pick up
some of this data and i had some clients
that that was a big that was a mission
for them essentially
for people not to search on google but
to switch on their platform
so they can have data like this
so think about this for a moment right
you you're searching on my platform
and how do i really get to understand
what you want i don't know you
i don't talk to you right the only thing
that i have to interact with you is this
search query that you give me
so if you actually don't have it it's
very difficult to really understand
what people are doing and um how you can
save them better
and get maybe more product out the door
and things like that
let's take a quick look at some history
of search
apache lucine that was i would say one
of the core inverted indexes that came
about
at scale from dog cutting back in 1999
and that led to apache solar
elasticsearch
i put this mongodb at the search was a
former colleague of mine
and he's running search at mongodb
which is kind of cool so you have these
three different flavors
and i may have mentioned that lucidworks
that i used to work for the guy who
started that he started up actually
solar on top of um
lucy so i'm a little more biased to
solar and what we've seen is
like solas does really really well at
scale
but that's still lexical based searching
you know
matching excuse me overlapping of texts
oftentimes with edit distance and other
things like that or tf idf
but this is what's happening now okay so
dense vector search is becoming very
popular
you're having a lot more data scientists
working in search and recommendations
and you know how are they going to start
playing
outside of the world of text okay
now we get into dense vector search
engines that's essentially multimodal
as it's saying here image text sound
ultimately i take my original
data set representation i do some
machine learning
and i encode that into some vector that
vector inherently has meaning
about maybe all those different types of
modalities
and now the goal is when a query comes
in or
when you ask for something matching in
that vector space
okay uh the two ones that you could
focus on are fives from facebook and
milbus these are open source
um but some companies are doing it you
know google
is obviously doing it and you'll see
some slides after uh lucid works does
integrate both
solar with milbus as well pinecone
just came out he was one of the guys
that did
sage maker so they're doing dense vector
search at scale
and things like that gene is also open
source
they have a lot of cool examples on
doing deep learning
type search and then elastic has this
thing called a dense
vector search type that allows you to
index vectors
after you've done some machine learning
to retrieve them from
from their leucine based index
very quickly what does what is vector
search
right as i'm saying here you're not
matching our text anymore right
you're able to match on vectors so just
think of anything that you want to
convert to a vector you can essentially
match
um like that and it's really good for
combining things and here's a good link
to learn more so good books for you to
keep in mind
on the left i usually consider this kind
of bible and information retrieval right
there's some things that
manning proposes in there that are very
relevant he has a really cool course on
deep learning in nlp on stanford
highly recommend you check it out if you
want to dig very deep
lucine in action is a good place trey's
book on
trade ranger's book on solo in action
you know if you're actually
someone working in solo that's like the
first book you should read
and he's also doing ai powered search
which i think will have some
crossover into the solar realm same
it'll
have analogs into elasticsearch as well
so for the elastic folks on the call
you can find something this is a
beautiful book super practical
he actually goes into examples of using
deep learning in search so if you wanted
to implement something it's pretty fun
uh relevant search is more about tuning
search engines fundamentally
and the thing that really struck a chord
with me was
i think yeah doug was saying in here
that hey you know
in regular lexical search you think of a
word as a feature
so oftentimes in machine learning i have
this vector of ten dimensions right so
each number in that vector
is is a feature almost right or when you
think of your data set you have features
in your data set but in lexical search
like a word is a feature i
i chop the word i expand the word and
that's how i manipulate
i get better features for search and
then if you're actually responsible for
the front end this is a good way to
present results
capture feedback on designing that
front-end system
all right so now we've moved into the
rise of language models
very simply right a language model has a
probability
has the ability to give the probability
of another word
right given some sequence that came in i
wanted to keep this super
high level but is one of the most
widely used ones in production not by
everyone i would say because
of sort of performance constraints
at inference time but as you can see
right tons of papers have been
presented on boot so this is kind of the
thing that's taken over
and then here's a little bit of proof
highly recommend you watch this video
from google on their updates to search
and this was the same guy who i got the
quote from in the beginning
but as you can see i think last year was
used for 10 percent of searches on
google
and they're saying it's pretty much on
every single search
and i don't know if you've seen their
new updates where
they actually start highlighting
sentences for you and that's basically
them
chunking up the document and allowing
boot to
their version of boots right there
productionized version of boot to
sort of rank if you're looking for a
very good paper on the history of
ranking and
that blending of lexical based searched
engines
with um you know this new type of dense
vector search
this is a fantastic paper i think this
guy did this phd and he wrote a really
nice summary
and if you wanted to dig into the sort
of details of boot and why transformers
work and what not
jay alaba's visualizations are fantastic
and once again every single thing in
this presentation has a link so you
don't need to go see it just click it
done
and enjoy reading when it comes to
language models
there is a plethora it is very confusing
especially for a beginner
um i highly recommend if you're in
production and your boss is telling you
improve search with machine learning
keep it simple
and you know maybe start off with boot
but maybe you can use some of these
diagrams to help you sort of find what's
the next best model
for you to look at right here's another
one
nfp model selection this is a link here
it's by this guy called critique
bobstar he's at feel free to join his
community called max pool
right it's a slack community they do
tons of stuff on nlp
so you can ask tons of questions in
there and he's really big into nlp and
search
but he did this cool thing where he
categorized
all these models by criteria so for
instance
if i wanted a an english model i'm doing
classification these are the ones that i
should select so
highly recommend you check that out
it'll it'll save you a lot of time
perfect so we just explored okay we
talked about lexical search then we
spoke a little bit about dance vector
search but hey
there's this thing called knowledge
graphs and you may have seen it at
google
so all this statement is trying to show
is that
um you know these things are important
for industrial applications
and all our knowledge graph means in in
reality it's
i have some notion of entities and how
they relate to each other
and how can i use that to generate
better recommendations and search
so most of everyone would have seen this
right you type in
you know some location or whatnot and
you get this bar on the right hand side
that's coming from their knowledge graph
i'd like to make sure and keep
the distinction between actual graph
traversal
versus just the concept of a knowledge
graph of things being connected to each
other right they're two separate
sort of problems to actually create the
relations and then to traverse the
relations
so don't get too caught up there
here has some examples of knowledge
graphs in production
uh amazon used this to do a bunch of
kobe 19 research
right to accelerate some things there
airbnb
use that to um sort of organize
their listings and and present listings
to folks in a better way
walmart's building a very big product
knowledge graph google has a big
product knowledge graph as well trying
to compete with amazon
amazon is developing their own um as
well
and like when you look at some of their
decks you know they
it's a very hard problem to solve it's
not easy and they're putting a lot of
resources behind it
and this paper is from home depot where
they're they're doing a lot of
excuse me knowledge graph type stuff as
well so it's not only
deep learning it's not only lexical
sewage but
it's also the hybrid of these three are
being used to present
sort of top of the line results okay
here's one thing i'd leave you with
if you decide to go down this rabbit
hole it is probably one of the biggest
rabbit holes that you can go down
and to get you know some value for your
money
uh please keep it non-trivial i would
focus on
i have a bunch of data um i want to
provide good search be it products be it
a bunch of documents
how do those things or how do entities
in those documents or things relate to
each other
focus on getting the relations first
because that's the harder problem
and then figure out at query time how do
i traverse across that data structure
very quickly okay
learning to rank this is you'll see this
with a lot of focused businesses so for
instance if i'm working at a single
company running search and
recommendations for that company
it's a good idea for maybe for me to
maybe
look at learning to rank and all you're
doing is you know you
send a request to let's say a lexical
based search engine you get the top end
results
you would have computed some features on
those before and you use different types
of algorithms to re-rank
based on the features right um deep
learning is playing a bigger part in
learning to rank
prior to that it was more i would say
count based features that were used to
you know match a query to a document but
now these algorithms are getting a lot
more advanced
keep in mind that if you do some type of
semantic search
right through like a boot encoder or
something it's inherently doing its own
sort of learning to rank under the hood
like it's finding up
it's finding the top end things based on
the query that you gave so
you might start to see this fizzler way
where more deep learning-based
approaches are coming in
all right let's talk about
considerations uh hopefully aaron i'm
doing well on time
so far okay perfect and
yeah my simple statement not to offend
anyone
we're in production right we're not
trying to get the best new hottest
algorithms working we're trying to make
money we're trying to save money
how we're trying to get you to keep your
job as well right
so keep that in mind keep it simple
four things to keep in mind what are the
types of data that you have
what are you going to do with that data
how are you going to crunch it right all
of the cost implications
maintenance of that infrastructure
things you have to think about
what types of algorithms are we going to
use and then
you know what are we going to do with
the things that come out of those
algorithms right
so when it comes to types of data
don't only think about the things that
you index into your search engine right
it's not only about those documents it's
about
what other people are doing with those
documents as well
right how they interact with them all of
that information can
be used to enhance your search and the
last thing i put there is metadata
metadata is both things from like
manufacturers or
other supporting documents but also
think about
hey like there may be some forums where
people describe
my products right and what you'll end up
seeing there's a discrepancy usually
between
a user's vocabulary and the vocabulary
that's describing your particular
documents i'll talk a bit more about
that later on
think about text versus multi-modal data
meaning if i'm indexing pattern
documents i'm not only going to look at
the text i'm actually
if i pay attention to the images there's
lots of ways that i can use
to improve search the lengths of
documents as you start doing more deep
learning based approaches that that will
become a bottleneck
it's typically some sequence length that
you get to
sort of predict on or index or train on
so
keep that in mind now they're different
sort of
that's what i'm looking for tokenization
strategies to
to to get around that this is very
interesting
i learned about this from some of my
colleagues where
if you're in e-commerce and you have a
bunch of different vendors
remember they want their product at the
top right so
if they can define their
their catalogue in a certain way where
it aligns best maybe to the customer
but it's very specific and their
competitors don't have that same type of
verbage
in a lexical based search engine
naturally they'll rise to the top so
you'll end up seeing
when in this multi-vendor environment
the data is extremely dirty
uh and it's almost intentional so keep
on keep a lookout for that
okay when you go to process some data
right you know call saturn cloud
probably just to make things easier and
that's actually a very serious statement
you
don't want to be spending time doing
that work you have to solve search
think about modularizing your index
pipelines meaning
i have data coming in from this source
and i'm going to maybe tokenize it
i may be injecting extra entities like
synonyms and whatnot
keep that thing as modular as possible
so you can debug
certain parts think about
if you have performance implications for
the indexing
speed of your data right so if someone's
using
you're getting a ton of new documents
coming in and you need them to be
available
that will change a lot of how you
process some of the data
and this is more around signal data
actually and when we go to
excuse me um process signal data that's
like a query on what someone clicked on
doing all of these getting that data
ready for
you know different types of machine
learning algorithms or just
helping out in ranking you have these
two options right
and saturn cloud i think makes rapids on
desk
quite easy right and that's a very
interesting alternative to spark
right if you do roll open source spark
um
you know it's not the version that
databricks uses right databricks
has much more optimized versions as well
so you you always want to plan
for that discrepancy i would say in
performance and
set up right but if you're just working
on your own application then
you're spending all day looking at that
but if you're providing this as a
service
um just check out dusk and rapids
so from a training algorithms
perspective uh
you know naturally you would not want
your training cluster to be on your
production search cluster
and this becomes more important at scale
like you know if you have a couple
thousand users
hitting your servers it's not going to
bottleneck certain things
uh here's an interesting one right the
thing where you store your
features doesn't have to be the same
thing as your search index meaning
i can have a lexical based search engine
regularly indexing text
but i also extract some features but
they sit in like a dance vector search
engine
right so now you have this hybrid
approach when a query comes in
i encode it i go check it against this
search engine i do an asynchronous
call to check my lexical based search
engine
and then you rank by maybe mixing some
scores
and lastly you know
when when you
get an output of an algorithm right you
want to track
hey what someone does with that
particular result
knowing hey it came from this algorithm
version
and that allows you to do some post
filtering the next time you go to do
some
retraining so the better you tag your
data the better filtering that you can
do
on the better algorithms that you can
produce
and this one is more or less the same as
that last point using the algorithm
output
this is very tricky if you're using like
a solar or elastic search and like a
dense vector search engine
and you're getting two different scores
typically that's on a query level
right that they're independent but you
know they have different scales so be
careful with your normalization
and you'll have to do some you know
really sit down and dig into some
details to
see what some good score blending
heuristics are for you keep
keep a track of the scores from your
model so for instance like hey
i put in this query it gave me back
these 10 different
documents but that would have had a
score with it
monitor the scale of those scores so if
you're doing
a heuristic based approach um that might
actually affect
you know how some of these results will
come out later on
and the next time you go to do
retraining right now you're getting into
the machine learning workflow it's not a
static search engine
where we are custom tuning some weights
on some fields
like this thing is going to change over
time you have to
keep into account seasonality if you're
doing black friday
please do not include your black friday
like e-commerce data
into your model like people behave
erratically
on those days so you know keep that data
separate and
you know hopefully you should keep some
good results
okay for the data scientists right you
know i want to put my
model in production ultimately you might
not need to get
really good accuracy performance
on the metrics that data scientists
measure um testing in production
is always good on you know some smaller
set of traffic
and make sure you're optimizing the
business metric right that's that's
super important if you're doing research
then
that gets thrown out the door and you
just you try to get the best performance
on that benchmark
but please keep that in mind and
beware if you're using signal data at
scale it's noisy
people search behavior is different at
different times of day
you'll see these pockets of people
searching some people just like to mess
with search
like search sites because they know that
people index that search data
so i like we've seen things that people
put in profanity
and then in the type ahead it'll show up
because like you're not looking for that
stuff so
yeah if you have some you know crazy
users like that be on the lookout
and as a business if you
say i'm gonna do machine learning and
i'm gonna curate these data sets myself
at scale that's that's very difficult
but big companies have that budget to
hire folks to
curate those data sets check
recommendations to see if they're good
um a good example of this is like
there's no ground truth for a
recommendation
if i have this glass right what's the
best recommended what's the best thing
to recommend for that right that's very
subjective
so don't get too caught up on on
measuring
hardcore machinery metrics for that's
the recommendations
okay bilbo says buy i know i have a
couple of bullets that's not
good uh presentation style but i wanted
you to have something to take away
but ultimately it comes down to head
count
this is the defining factor when you go
to make this decision right how many
data scientists do you have
and in my opinion you want your data
scientists
doing solving the hardest problems that
you have
not solving sort of solved problems by
other vendors
right so i think it might be a good idea
to eat the cost because they end up
maintaining that particular piece of the
infrastructure
and you're able to just integrate all of
the extra
things that you're doing um with your
data science resources
the main thing to think about in any
platform that you choose
especially for search from a vendor make
sure that you can bring your own models
the last position that you want to be in
as a search owner
or that product owner is hey you're just
stuck with the
machine and capabilities of a vendor
right you want to be able to roll your
own
into that same pipeline and that'll make
sure you can minimize risk
of performance okay we're getting to the
end here
and please just pay attention for me and
if you kind of fizzle out so far
this is the one this is the money maker
i've seen
signals generate millions and millions
and millions of dollars
in very very simple ways right
so a good thing for you to think about
is becoming intimate with the signal
data and really trying to ask like what
is the delta
okay like if you read this first thing
i'm saying
identify what people want versus what
you have this is the fundamental problem
of search
right uh you are not chances are you are
not google right
you you might be internal search your
own business
so you have a more bounded problem to
solve meaning
i have a thousand items indexed somebody
comes in and they want a car but i sell
planes like i only have planes right so
i'm not going to focus on the person
that wants a car
that's a contrived example but however
keep that in mind when you go to try to
solve your search
trying to align the vocabulary of your
users
to the vocabulary that's in your index
okay and signals are a good place to
mine synonyms do
learn how to do rewrites and type ahead
things that you wouldn't
automatically generate on your own
it's a cool site uh it's a company
called databit machine
so they look at some of your signal data
and they help you to find you know
better queries to purchase
that will you know based on that um
better probability of someone to engage
with content on more specific queries
okay and they're typically cheaper and
i mentioned this before but look for
synonyms phrases and specifications
so the way that someone might specify
hardware is based on some lingo
so go mine all of that um sort of forum
data and include that in your index
and that's a great way to to win
essentially
uh i think i have i have some extras
so but pausing here right we've taken a
quick look at hey what's the new
landscape of
switching recommendations you saw like
dense vector searches coming up a lot
if you're at scale thinking about
knowledge graphs even if you're not at
scale
like even if you can manually create
your own knowledge graph based on some
of your knowledge
that can also help you as well when you
start thinking about
implementing um decision recommendations
from more machine learning perspective
making sure your pipelines are modular
both your index and
what i call your query pipelines as well
you know
we always bound to some type of a
response constraint meaning like 50
milliseconds 100 milliseconds
so you might have the world's best
algorithm for ranking
but it takes 300 milliseconds and you
know your boss is telling you
hey i need this thing under you know 75
milliseconds or something so
that all the research went out the door
and lastly
think about how you can expand your
business with signal data
right oftentimes people are looking for
things and if you don't stock those
things but you have maybe capabilities
to partner with someone who has those
things you can easily sell it
sort of on your site and we saw a lot of
that in some of our customers where
like people were coming they weren't
finding certain things but
like they were able to stock it and
generate revenue right that's more in
the e-commerce case
and wrapping up here uh i'm
releasing me and some colleagues are
releasing a paper
uh kind of around this stuff right we're
calling it a guide to machine learning
in search
i won't ask you to read the abstract
i'll just sort of explain it
most academic research is trying to win
a benchmark
right oftentimes it's not really geared
towards production
uh it's not beginner friendly sometimes
so this was just an effort to
hey it's kind of a detailed version of
this deck where we go into some things
things to think about places to look but
more importantly
research is no longer bounded to the
academic community it's now
involved like you know saturn will
produce research companies will produce
research
so who do you actually network with
where do you go to find code all of that
stuff will be in there
hopefully uh in may just keep a look out
for that
now that i'm at a video i'm seeing a
whole different world when it comes to
deploying let's say deep learning models
right so i highly recommend
anyone doing deep learning check out
this thing called the triton
in front server there are many different
model deployment frameworks
what's very interesting about this one
is you know nvidia owns that hardware so
they spend a lot of time optimizing
these libraries
to sort of deploy on the gpu hardware
and this is more
for deep learning good place to check it
out links at the top
tensor rt if you're currently doing any
type of training
or deployment of machine learning models
these are some extra
it's using different cores on your gpus
and i think it only works as
certain gpus but what's really cool
about this is if you have a business
where you're training models centrally
and you're deploying to the edge
or you have different domains where your
models have to live in different places
it's optimized for all of nvidia's
hardware so
that's kind of cool and if you're doing
recommenders check out nvidia merlin
it's then you recommend a framework
coming out um doing a bunch of
rapid stuff crunching data on gpus
uh highly recommend you check out this
keynote
um they put a lot of effort into it
watch the keynote 2020 it's like seven
minutes at least the first part
but you're gonna see some really cool
things come on some things i can't say
yet
and i guess yeah check out gtc as well
there are over like 1400 sessions so
there's tons of
stuff on recommenders and i think
there'll be some stuff on search so
yeah any questions you can find us on
linkedin and
hopefully uh you've enjoyed at least the
50 000 foot view
thank you very much mark that was
awesome i really enjoyed uh listening to
that talk learned a lot
um if anybody has questions we do have a
few minutes for questions now
um so feel free to uh either unmute or
ask your question or post something in
the chat and i can read it off and then
mark uh can answer i i do have a couple
actually questions to kick things off um
you you were talking about like i i
thought was really interesting what you
said about like the vendor data like the
third party vendor data and like
perhaps it not being as clean or people
like maybe trying to push their
results to the top have you seen or are
there like techniques for actually
trying to like pull out and handle any
of those like
bad actors or people like trying to game
the system and like
the thing that i could think of is like
maybe amazon merchants trying to put in
specific keywords into their things that
maybe aren't related but that are
boosting the signal of their products
you know
yep and you know everyone's trying to
especially in e-commerce right
everyone's trying to game
game those algorithms that's why i think
looking at your signal data
is extremely important so for instance
if i
took all my signal data i looked at
these products that were purchased
i looked at all the queries that led to
it and looks let's say we focus on the
specification problem
right these vendors are specifying their
data in a certain way and now icd users
are specifying it in
a different way um you know making those
types of associations i think you can
begin to normalize data
in terms of hey if 85 of people
this describe things in centimeters i'll
put a greater weight on centimeters or
something like that right that's sort of
a contrived example but
the point being when you see situations
that are occurring
go check your signal data to see because
what's most important is that people
find things right
vendors can fight against each other but
the main thing is that people find
things that they want
so i would i would more focus on that
sort of approach there and
yeah i haven't i haven't dug too much
into like normalization algorithms where
you'd automatically be predicting all
right i put in this query and then i
give you this normalized version that's
kind of like a sequence to sequence type
thing where i'm generating a new
sequence
matching some of your dimensions but
that's that's a little trickier problem
on the deep learning side
sure makes sense thank you uh so we've
had a question about from philip
about the video and deck being shared so
yeah we'll share that
um the video should be posted probably
tomorrow on the pi
data youtube channel and i'll make sure
to put a comment on the meetup page that
way everybody has access to the
recording and the slides um phil i also
had another question actually asked
could you expand a bit on knowledge
graph building perhaps there are any
resources or frameworks to look into
yeah um so this is a
i need to tread trend carefully right so
the first thing i would ask is
you know what scale are you talking
right are you talking airbnb scale
walmart scale
then you start getting into i have so
much traffic coming in
that i need to respond very quickly so
you need bigger hardware so you need
more performance i would say graph
traversal algorithms
um knowledge graph when i sort of speak
about it at its highest level
is just the the entities that you've
described or pulled out of your data
versus
excuse me um how they relate to each
other so a very interesting point is
that
in e-commerce you essentially have a
knowledge graph already there but it's
just unconnected meaning
you know a product exists as itself
there's glasses exists on its own as a
product
this phone exists on its own versus
let's say you're in finance and you have
finance documents
there may be so many entities inside of
a single document like names locations
persons companies
so understanding what domain you're in
and in terms of frameworks
um any other standard like neo4j
guys i think there's like a tiger graph
um
but then you start getting into rdf
graphs versus property graphs and and
that takes you down a rabbit hole that
to me it's a little more
that's an easier problem to solve when
you have the relations already encoded
so i would almost just
put this thing in a flat file where you
know this company is related to this
person that company is related to that
person and then
you might include that in your index to
query or include it as a synonym
but i would say neo4j to answer from a
resources perspective
and some of those links that i had there
go check out those articles and they'll
go into why
they focused on um knowledge graphs
cool um we've got a couple more minutes
and if anybody has questions feel free
to unmute now or
uh post it in the chat
um actually uh mark uh i know that you
sent me a link to the slides on linkedin
is that
the best link can i actually just drop
that to everybody now yeah you could
drop it now and what i'll do is um
i'm gonna re-upload this version i put
some extra slides on there and things
but
most of the links in there are quite the
same so feel free to share that version
absolutely
okay great so i'm going to post that in
the chat now just so everybody knows an
updated one will be
coming shortly and somebody's asking for
the pi data youtube
if you just search pi data on youtube
they know that that
channel will come up in all of the
different meetup chapters
and conferences from pi data posts there
so there's definitely a lot of good
content
on it um and like i said i'll post it in
the meetup uh
page once once ours is posted
i can offer a question yeah uh mark
thank you for the
very good presentation my question has
to do with
uh visualization tools for common signal
collections
so you've got all of these signals that
have come in over javascript
how you've scrolled how long you looked
at an image what your mouse movements
were
whether you zoomed in or not things that
are less tangible than did you click and
did you buy
yes is is there a visualization tool
something like google analytics for the
clicks
uh but instead for the the signals that
you could use to visualize the data
and develop some kind of idea of what
you have and what direction you want to
try to take it with
i think the first my short answer is
is no like i hadn't seen any
visualization stuff and that's
some of the stuff before i left lucy
works that was one of the ideas is hey
how do i
look at these associations at a sort of
macro level
right the first thing i would say is to
make sure that
you tie your signals together meaning in
time right so i have this query
someone clicks on something or even if
they didn't click on it
i think it's even more valuable to know
the dwell times and things like you're
expressing
right and then i would almost do a
simple filtering so for instance if you
put everything
um in pandas like you know this person
want i look at all
a user's data so it's almost looking at
different views
of the data right and i would actually
just use pandas to
sort of do some data frame visualization
and keep it in python for now
especially if it's not big scale so i
would look at a user view so for this
user what are all the things that they
did
so um you could do some bokeh plots bok
h is a good thing to use like okay and
you could probably build like a
streamlit app on top of it so you can
give it to like a business owner
where they can you know toggle different
buttons to see different views of that
data
right so rounding out that point if you
had a user view
so this user did all of these different
actions and you can just count the
amount of actions that different users
use
that's one form of segmentation so show
me all users that had
four actions or who spent more than 10
seconds
on a particular item or type of item you
see what i'm saying
yes sounds like there's an opportunity
for a business there
absolutely everyone's collecting the
same signals
in fact when i'm on facebook i feel like
i'm being psychologically profiled
uh more than i'm getting out of it and
they're getting out
of very uh my new details about my
impulses
yeah and when you spend a lot of time in
search and you see a bunch of different
search data from different customers
what you realize is
people fix your search right if people
want something from your site
and your search sucks they're gonna get
it they're gonna
put in this query they're gonna scroll
to the 10th page and find it so if
you're not using that you're not
leveraging the work that folks are doing
to
to make your search better that's why
google just has one bar
tell me what you want and they're going
to have all those associations behind
the hood
they have you on the chrome browser so
they can track everything in there as
well
so all the things that you're talking
about they're leveraging under the hood
to you know i don't want to say profile
you but
pretty much get a very good picture of
what what and who you are
thank you absolutely
cool i i do have one more and i think
that might be the last part okay
yeah getting a lot for you um i you were
talking about
using like different models and like
obviously like trying to combine
it's kind of might be more difficult to
combine the predictions from multiple
different types of models that might be
in your search or
you know coming from different places
for like somebody kind of going after
this and like
building out you know some search models
would you think about like trying to
perfect
one model that you have with one data
source let's just say like
like text based um or like lexical right
or should you kind of try to maybe like
diversify like where your data is coming
from i know it might depend
you know you know what i mean like
tweaking squeezing out performance from
one model or like
you know stacking different ones yeah um
the first thing i'll say to that is
let's look at the hardware that you're
running on
right first of all for bigger language
models you need bigger hardware
to do in front right so the first thing
is what's my response time let's
if we really focus on search what's the
response time i have to
to go after that'll filter a bunch of
different algorithms that you can use
on let's say if you had a certain amount
of hardware dedicated to it
and then if you know what your service
level agreement is for your response
time
the hardware that you have look at the
pool of algorithms that you have there
and i would say focus on one
first right and see how good that you
can get and be like all right well
i actually need to maybe try a dual
approach right to see if
you're on something two different
methods um so i would do one at a time
for sure
not all three three four or five that'll
especially if you're just yourself like
no
gotcha makes sense that makes sense
perfect
great okay well um looks like the whole
crowd stuck around for the
for the whole talk so that's awesome um
thank you again so much mark
absolutely and it's pleasure speaking
with all of you all and hope you have a
great day
awesome well thanks again everybody stay
tuned for our next meet up we're going
to post a video
like i said probably tomorrow so thanks
all for coming see everyone
bye